[Music]
Katy Perry Lionel Richie and Luke Bryan
gush over Carrie Underwood's epic return
to American Idol I think she's a goddess
it's been 13 years since the 35 year old
country singer won Idol and on Sunday
she returned to her roots to help coach
the five remaining contestants of the
season
it does feel pretty full circle this is
like looking in a mirror
13 years ago Carrie also hit the stage
to perform her latest hit cry pretty
[Music]
et was with the Idol judges backstage
after the show where they had nothing
but praise for Underwood so happy that
she did she's so ethereal beautiful
powerful and it was wonderful to hear
her say some of the things that we have
yet to been able to reach out as we
don't talk to these kids we just see
them when they're on the stage and so
she really helps steer their ships and I
think she just forgot us all while doing
it mm-hmm you know what that you took
the words out of my mouth as far as I'm
concern is a very famous alum alumni
come back to the school and just tell us
exactly how they did it and how they
feel now and she nailed it right well I
mean yeah when you think about I mean
just her impact on music and culture and
society I mean you walk you know she's
hosting major country awards shows for
multiple years been movie stars and and
that's called seizing the moment I mean
and at some point that top ten top five
top three they'll they will have to
seize their moment they can't just
they can't just wait for the phone to
ring they gotta I gotta go I've never
done anything
[Music]
[Applause]
you